I think we'll see tons of different
business models for media in the future
one that I think will dominate is
networks not the idea that everything
that is produced has to be owned by one
conglomerate but instead there's a
network loosely joined if you look at
the old media model exemplified by any
publishing company or media company or
for that matter Yahoo the old media
model says I own or control or syndicate
this content I'm going to mark it to
bring people into me and then i'm going
to show you ads and then a little wave
goodbye and that's where yahoo and so on
the new media model i think is more of a
network where I have my own blog I don't
necessarily want to sell it to anybody I
want to publish it myself but a site
could come along and say oh I like that
post let me take that post from you or
all let me sell your ads because you're
oh you're okay or let's promote each
other some different relationship the
idea of a network i think is the way
that journalism and media can in fact
expand a local newspaper a city of
newspaper could never have afforded to
cover all the towns and neighborhoods in
the market but with the help of its
public they can now so what's the
relationship of that big newspaper to
those individuals who are going out and
maybe reporting the school board bean or
the the kids soccer game it may be a
financial relationship where they sell
the ads it may be a Content relationship
where they curate the content it may be
an educational relationship where they
help them understand how to do it better
it may be a promotional relationship
where they send traffic to each other if
you think more like a network you're
thinking more like Google and that is
how google has expanded greatly Google
unlike yahoo does not own tons of
content it wants to own none but it
wants to organize it all and so I think
if you think that way and say okay I'm a
newspaper instead of trying to own the
content on the market if I instead
enable the market to know as much as I
can about itself and use as many means
to do that as I can I think that then
media companies will be able to grow
bigger at lower costs and less risk and
we'll have a better relationship with
the public they serve
you